بالعوده الى التدابير المؤقته الصادره عن
محكمه العدل الدوليه في لاهاي تنضم الينا
من لاهاي الان الدكتوره ناليدي باندور
وزيره خارجيه جنوب افريقيا مرحبا بك سيده
الوزيره هل خاب املكم بان محكمه العدل
الدوليه لم تصدر قرارا او دعوه صريحه بوقف
اطلاق النار لاسرائيل كما كانت طالبت دعوه
جنوب
افريقيا
اعتقد انني بالتاكيد كان لدي امال بان وقف
اطلاق النار سيتم ذكره لكنني لم اتوقع بان
الحكومه ستذهب الى المدى الذي اتخذته
ووصلت اليه في مساله الاجراءات المؤقته
بالتالي هنالك خيبه امل طفيفه لكن في نفس
الوقت انا راضيه على اننا قدمنا هذه
القضيه والتي نتجت عنها هذه
الاجراءات المؤقته والتي تمت التوصل اليها
بالقرارات من قبل المحكمه رده الفعل
الاسرائيليه الاوليه دكتوره ناليدي باندور
هي ان اسرائيل مستمره في فيما تسميه
دفاعها دفاعها عن النفس كيف تلقيتم رده
الفعل
هذه
علي ان اقول انني شخصيا توقعت رد الفعل
هذا من اسرائيل لست متفاجئه هذا هو كان
الرد المستمر من حكومه اسرائيل لسنوات
عديده تجاه القمع الذي مارسته ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني الان ما ننظر اليه هو
ان المزيد من الدول يجب ان تنضم الى دوله
جنوب افريقيا في هذه القضيه في الوقت الذي
يتم فيه اخذ الاجراءات من قبل المحكمه هم
توصلوا ان
هنالك قضايا واضحه وذات مصداقيه يجب النظر
اليها والتحقيق فيها واعتقد ان المجتمع
الدولي عليه ان يضم الجهود مع دوله جنوب
افريقيا ومع فلسطين من اجل ان نستمر في
هذه المراحل مراحل التحقيق في هذه القضيه
هل تعملون على انضمام دول اخرى دكتوره
نلدي
نعم نعم نحن كذلك عدد من الدول تواصلت
معنا وكل منها طلبت منها طلبت كل واحده
منها
انها ستعلن خلال الاسابيع الدماء ان
قرارها بالانضمام الى دوله جنوبه افريقيا
اجتمعنا هنا في لهاي مع عده وفود لكنهم
سيقومون باتخاذ الاعلانات من جانبهم
بالتالي ما سنقوم به الان يجب علينا ان
نتفاءل بان اصدقاء اسرائيل في المجتمع
الدولي سيقدمون النصح لاسرائيل من اجل ان
تحترم قرارات المحكمه واذا لم تتحرك
اسرائيل بالطريقه المناسبه س يجب عليهم ان
يوضحوا دعمهم لقرارات المحكمه ومنظومه
الامم المتحده من اجل ضمان نجاحها
المحكمه قالت ان اسرائيل عليها العوده بعد
شهر اليها من اجل التاكد انها امتثلت
للتدابير المؤقته ما الذي يمكن فعله في
غضون هذا الشهر من اجل التاكد ان تستمر
اله القتل والتدمير كما
هي اعتقدوا ان مساله التقرير هي
الاهم الاهم من توجيهات والاوامر التي
اصدرتها المحكمه لانه غالبا تقوم منظمات
الامم المتحده بالقرارات لكنها لا تقوم
بوضع اليه لمراقبه التطبيق بالتالي خلال
الشهر سيكون لدينا مؤشرات واضحه اذا ما
قامت اسرائيل باحترام القانون الدولي كما
تدعي او انها لا تحترم هذا القانون كما
نعتقد نحن ولكن التفسير الاولي الاسرائيلي
هذه القرارات دكتوره ن لندي هو الاستمرار
بهذه الحرب وبالتالي الاستمرار بما كنا
نراه خلال الاشهر الماضيه كيف يمكن وضع حد
لهذا
الامر الان كما قلت اعتقد ان اسرائيل
عليها ان تستمع
لنصائح حلفائها
واصدقائها والذين قالوا لها
ان ابرياء يتم قتلهم وانه يجب السماح
للمساعدات الانسانيه بالدخول الى غزه
وبالتالي علينا جميعا ان نراقب اسرائيل
وهي تقوم بتطبيق اوامر المحكمه اذا لم
تقبل اسرائيل بذلك بالتالي لدينا اسس
واضحه
لمساله ارتكاب اسرائيل لجريمه الاباده
الجماعيه هل يمكن دكتوره
ناليدي قريبا رفع هذه القرارات الصادره
اليوم عن محكمه العدل الدوليه الى مجلس
الامن ما هي الاليه بهذا
الشان بالتاكيد
سيكون هنالك اجراءات وهذا هو المتبع عاده
لكن ما سنرحب به انه
سيكون علينا ان نرى بالاست
بعيدا عن مجلس الامن نحب ان نرى اسرائيل
تقوم باتخاذ اجراءات ملموسه تطبيقا
للاوامر التي اصدرتها المحكمه اول خطوه
متمثله بالمساعدات الانسانيه
التي تصل هذه المساعدات الى الناس في
فلسطين وان ايضا يتم تلبيه
الاحتياجات الاساسيه من قبل للناس لسكان
غزه والفلسطينيين الغذاء والما وال يجب ان
يكون يتم التعامل مع هذا الامر على انه
اولويه طيب وماذا ايضا عن الدول التي تمكن
اسرائيل تدعم اسرائيل في هذه الحرب وتورد
لاسرائيل السلاح اي تداعيات لهذه التدابير
المؤقته الصادره عن المحكمه على هذه
الدول كما تعرفون
عندما يكون هنالك عده اجراءات مؤقته كالتي
صدرت اليوم هذا مؤشر واضح على انه اذا ما
تم الاستمرار
ب بدعم اسرائيل با اجراءاتها واعمالها
وتقديم الدعم لها فان تلك الدول هؤلاء
القاده
سيصبحون
طرفا في القضيه في قضيه الاباده الجماعيه
بالتالي اعتقد انه تم
اطلاق تحذير واضح له تلك الدول
وللقاضي جب ان تقوم اسرائيل باحترام حقوق
الانسان قبل قليل الاتحاد الاوروبي
اصدر موقفا قال فيه انه يتوقع تنفيذا
فوريا وكاملا من اسرائيل لقرار لقرارات
محكمه العدل كيف تقيمون هذا الموقف
نحن سننتظر
الافعال ما تريده جنوب افريقيا افعال
واضحه كان هنالك الكثير من
التصريحات هذا الامر دفعنا الى التوجه الى
المحكمه لدينا الان اوامر واضحه من
المحكمه ما نريده الان هو تطبيق واضح
واجراءات واضحه وما توقعاتكم بالنسبه
للموقف الامريكي
انا اعرف وقد تحدثت مع الوزير بلينكن
الليله الماضيه وقد
وافق
معنا حول مساله ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه وضمان ان المساعدات الانسانيه
يتم
توفيرها وايضا وافق على ان عددا كبيرا من
المدنين قد قتل
ووافق على مساله منع الاذى عن المدنيين
وقال انه يجب علينا ان نضمن ان كوادر
الامم المتحده وطواقم الاغاثه يتم حمايتهم
وقد كرر مساله توفير
الحمايه ايضا وافقنا على ان من
المهم جدا للمجتمع الدولي و خصوصا
الولايات
المتحده ان تبدا
بعمليه
مناقشه حل الدولتين بطريقه فعاله هذا
اساسي واساسي ان تقوم الولايات المتحده
خلال من خلال منظومه الامم المتحده بلعب
دور فعال ذكرتي سيده
الوزيره عند درج امام المحكمه انك تعتبرين
ان التزام اسرائيل بالتدابير المؤقته
الصادره عن المحكمه يستلزم ان يتم وقف
اطلاق النار هل تعتقدين ان الولايات
المتحده ربما في هذه المرحله تشارككم في
مثل هكذا
تفسير ما قلته
انه بالتطبيق لا يمكن تنفيذ هذه الاوامر
لم يكن هنالك وقف لاطلاق النار لا يمكن
نقل المساعدات الانسانيه مواد الاغاثه اذا
لم يكن هنالك وقف لاطلاق النار لا يمكننا
توفير الماء والغذاء والوقود اذا لم يكن
هنالك وقف لاطلاق النار بالتالي ما يجب
مناقشته هو وقف اطلاق النار من اجل ان
نضمن تطبيق هذه الاوامر على الرغم من ان
كلمه وقف اطلاق النار لم يتم ذكرها في
القرار لكن كل هذه الاوامر كل الاوامر
المؤقته تتطلب
وقفا لاطلاق النار بالتاكيد على حماس ان
تمتثل
لهذه الاوامر وايضا في مساله الرهائن يجب
التعامل مع هذا الامر ايضا اشكرك دكتوره
نالن باندور وزيره خارجيه جنوب افريقيا من
لاهاي